head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smoky Mike in the god king
that's Jeremy boring and Michael nolles
and with your help we will smash our way
onto the Billboard charts a tweet from
James O'Keefe James do you want to uh uh
read this out and explain what's going
on yeah so this is a you're looking at
here I don't think anyone has reported
this at least our team has not been able
to find this on the internet if I'm if I
stand corrected let me know this is
breaking news from Phoenix Sky Harbor
airport this week you're looking at a a
ticket counter piece of paper um this is
given to immigrants illegal immigrants
coming in the United States they they
ship them from different parts of
Arizona to a Welcome Center a School in
Phoenix and then they're picked up in
limousines I'm not I'm not making this
up black cars that's an inside joke
black cars by the way did you know
nonprofits are not allowed to hire black
cars it's against IRS rules but these
nonprofits yes I'm just I'm making a
joke ah uh project baratas joke there um
so these immigrants are picked up in
black cars and dropped off at the
airport and these are documents that
were given to me by various airport
insiders it says quote please help me
print my boarding pass I am a refugee
and I do not speak the language thank
you we've redacted the confirmation
number there to protect The Insider at
the airport and a lot of these
immigrants are not from Mexico they're
from all different countries across
across the world uh the government
claims it's vetting these individuals
prior to putting them up on planes but
we're reporting that uh a lot of the
Insiders tips contradict that we found
that agents responsible for vetting the
identification are relying solely on
their word and they don't speak English
so it's it's fascinating here Tim and
and and just to backtrack for a minute
uh for the audience I was I was outside
this airport the airline insiders
confronted me oh my gosh James O'Keefe
you have to help us every 30 minutes the
buses pull up I interviewed the bus
driver he said he was with a company
called jet limousines and then we were
able to figure out where they pick these
people up it's at a Welcome Center in
Phoenix Arizona and they hire these car
services to drop them off the airports
and they're shipped across the country
New Jersey New York and places like that
and technically I think you would call
that smuggling them across the country
you might you might call that smuggling
I wand attack I followed up with
Williamson last night whose brother we
talked about immigration a bit and her
brother does immigration uh he's a
lawyer and and said that her brother
said that each of these individuals
should be receiving a what's called a
credible fear interview and if you
cannot establish that they have
legitimate credible fear you send them
back immediately you cannot take people
in we we haven't done that for years
right the thing about the border is that
this has been an issue for decades and
every political party has flipped up it
Bill Clinton in his like 1995 State of
the Union Address said every American
should be concerned about the number of
illegal immigrants coming across the
border and instead we just left a broken
system to get worse and worse and worse
no wonder airline pilots and all sorts
of community members are frustrated by
this I just think it's really funny that
this like Turning Point sent all of
these conservative people to Arizona
while this was happening and everyone in
the airport was noticing this right I
mean that was the thing Ashley was there
for it you were there for that hold our
crew who flew through Chicago on their
way saw the same thing in Chicago so we
before even getting to TP USA we're
getting messages from our crew being
like Hey we're on a plane it's all
illegal immigrants like all they've got
the bags that and I'm and we're like wow
and then they're being dropped off in
Chicago the East Coast I get hundreds of
these messages from people and say they
I can't say who they are hey this is my
throwaway account I set up a fake X
don't reveal my name so I don't get in
trouble but I know the location that we
drop off migrants from nales Tucson Yumi
here in Phoenix so they all can go to
Phoenix Sky Harbor and uh they drop them
off at this school this this Welcome
Center this school now turned Welcome
Center we get hundreds of people coming
in and uh and anyway I'm going back to
Phoenix to to follow up on this because
this is a fascinating story and they
have all these car companies that they
hire I'm trying to figure out who's
doing this is the feds the state there's
a lot more who's paying for it who's
paying for it and by the way one more
thing about this Tim this whistleblowing
let me just add that there's nowhere for
these people to actually these insiders
to go obviously they can't go to the New
York Times yep cuz they'll hunt those
people down like a trophy buck and print
their real name
but but there's no one you got to have
guts to publish these stories you know
and uh citizen journalism here I think
it is not hyperbole to say the 2024
election is or is the last
election we got until the next one no I
mean it it in terms of what this country
is this is it however however only if
Joe Biden or the Democrats win and I
don't think it's hyperbolic um when you
look at what's going on the federal
government has been
facilitating
the mass illegal migration into this
country to the point where black
residents in Chicago are on video right
now screaming this this no joke an
elderly black man got up at at a meeting
and said Trump get in here and clean
this mess up I'm like wow when the
Chicago black community is so fed up
with the abuse they are yelling for a
republican that's how bad it's gotten if
the Democrats win in 2024 we will not
survive four more years of 10,000 plus
illegal immigrants every day what is
your hypothesis that are they going to
let let uh them Vote or what do you
think you mentioned something about camp
in Boston recently uh Boston recently
passed a bill for non-citizens to vote
New York has had similar Provisions uh
cities in California have had similar
Provisions yes we are we are Marching
towards we are a couple years away if
the Democrats win non-citizens illegal
immigrants will will be slowly granted
voting powers and they're all considered
refugees because they can just claim
that I guess anybody can claim to be a
refugee I probably should go to Mexico
and just slide I mean this is dangerous
but wear a hidden camera and just go
across the border and disguise and just
go through the whole process that would
be a good idea if we have any brave
people that want to sign up on the OMG
website what would happen if the US
brought in 15 million illegal immigrants
mostly fighting age males and then just
load them up on boats and shipped them
off to like the Taiwan like to Taiwan
and been like okay now you defend this
place but Democrats never let that
happen because we use illegal immigrants
to throw off the census data right
remember when Trump was like I would
like the uh immigration status to be on
the census andat citizenship status and
they were like absolutely not that's
crazy you're so racist well I wonder why
right like this is something that is the
the only reason someone would allow for
this to happen is if they benefit it for
benefit from it in some way and that's
the issue here right all of the illegal
immigrants especially those who are
actually you know smuggled brutalized
brought across and really dangerous
restrictive terrible conditions I mean
there was a story two months ago about a
shipping container full of I think it
was 60 people who were all dead they
were being trafficed across the border
this is a brutal problem for everyone
involved right I don't think you should
cross into the country illegally but I
also think that by incentivizing illegal
immigrations by saying if you get here
we'll just put you on an airplane and
send you wherever you want to go we are
making all kinds of people take crazy
risk that we shouldn't encourage I I
think it it could happen that a bunch 15
million IM immigrants come across
illegally and then get shipped off to
Taiwan to defend the island or to either
Ukraine to defend Ukraine but then
they'd still get their census tally at
whatever state they were in before they
got shipped out and they get their
citizenship if they survive if you're an
illegal M you put in State this is one
of the issues right so if you come
across the board illegally they'll say
you have a court date it's in three
years from now but then you never go to
that court date so I don't know how we
would then recall all of the people we
allowed in illegally you'd have to
immediately send them and we we aren't
good at that we'd rather send them
wherever they want to go in the US even
though they don't have I tend to keep
this pretty I I keep my reporting pretty
factual without making judgments how do
you handle I do see about 20% of
comments uh you know the kind of the
empathy people have for these poor
people who are in a horrible place just
trying to have a better life how do you
deal with that talking point from people
these poor people want to have a better
life yeah that that type of thing you
get I I welcome them with open arms I
hope every poor person in the world who
wants to come to America comes to
America through the legal process
properly right and that legal process
means it might take him 20 years but
they're all welcome to apply and uh join
our community done right why uh you get
this talking point like Maran Williamson
said the other day migrants are a boost
to the economy and like yes you are
absolutely correct when managed properly
right when they when we bring migrants
in like we did she says how many of your
grandparents you know were migrants and
I'm like right when they arrived on
Ellis Island and said now we will
integrate and we will assimilate and be
like the Americans that's not what
they're doing today today they're
cutting the the razor wine saying
everybody quick run and they're dumping
these people in Chicago where they have
nowhere to go and now Chicago is like
we're going to build mass
camps okay look what do you call large
camps and I mean this a literal question
not a rhetorical one what do you call
large camps where they house a part like
a political faction of people you know
the problem is I don't want to say
concentration camp because everyone just
immediately thinks Nazi Germany I am not
arguing for prison or death camps but
quite literally they are going to create
migrant detention camps these people are
being shipped in in Chicago and they're
putting up they're building fences and
and I think one of them got delayed but
they're putting them in schools they're
putting them in police
stations I if Trump wins in 2024 I can
already tell you what 2025 is going to
look like Donald there's going to be
videos of people being loaded up onto
trains onto buses and sent to camps for
deportation and the left is going to
Screech like banshees he's Hitler it's
happening again Heaven's me quick
everyone take up your arms they want
it's it's it's it's 4D chess across the
board right everybody is playing some
Advanced strategy of Victory lawsuits
are being prepared and what we're seeing
today will have massive impacts in the
next two or three years and longer
obviously throughout the history of this
country or what's left of it but what's
being done today there is a plan for
what comes next yeah I I told you guys
this I think you and Michael mice the
other night I Einstein when the Nazis
were coming to power he saw it early and
got out of the country and fled to the
United States and people have already
fled the US I am I'm feeling that right
now and I don't like that but that is
what I feel and what I see is like yo if
Mass illegal immigration record high
inflation World Wars all popping up all
over the place the people arresting
their political opponents like okay guys
and I don't want to blackpill you and I
don't want to give up on this wonderful
Constitution we got but what does the
country even mean is it the land that
you live on is it the Constitution
that's bit is it the people that are
running the military like what is this
country
I mean that's the question right I don't
know where you would like to go if you
were to leave the us one of the is
Salvador El Salvador maybe I mean there
are interesting places one of the issues
is countries are built on a sense of
patriotism and a sense of community and
loyalty right and so you would
theoretically want to stay and fix it on
the other hand I understand the instinct
to be like it's it's just going up in
Flames I I need to leave and I think
that there are people who immigrated to
the US from their own countries Al
immigrated here who made the same
decision and I wonder what their
conversation is like right now do we
stay in the us where we went for a
better life or and try and fix it I met
a guy at MGM National Harbor playing
poker and uh you know you're at the
poker table you're you're shooting a
you're talking and he mentioned he
was from El Salvador and I was like oh I
hear it's uh I hear it's getting really
really good down there this was a few
months ago and he goes yeah actually my
family's moving back you're going back
to El Salvador he's like yeah crime is
weigh down the econom is doing really
well so my family wants to go home
better to be a poor farmer than medal in
the politics how is the first amendment
in El Salvador I I don't know the
politics of that they have a article 3
courts protect the first I think it's a
very important thing in the United
States I think the the issue is is not
about the constitution in the first
amendment when we had free speech in the
70s they still arrested George Carlin
for swearing the the the issue is do you
have good leaders and so my view is I I
I I believe that na belli would respect
legitimate journalistic endeavor
who's that he's the current president
although I'm not going to pretend to
know enough about the the government
functions and guaranteed rights they the
the corporate president United States
argued that he was a despit for
arresting all these gang members and
cartel members and things like that but
you know spare me these people are the
New York Times Are grotesque monsters
yes I mean I think that's the next
that's one of the tests that we're going
to find here in this year is is is the
limits of the First Amendment because
you you talk about camps in Chicago I I
that may be true but if that is true I
guarantee T there's going to be video
inside of there and things leaking like
a Civ we're going to get so much
information I think I think what you're
going to see this year is going to be
horrible that's the bad news the good
news is all the horrible things will be
captured on video and leaked to the
world but my concern is deep FES what's
coming I think see everyone always talks
about Ai and and if I knew the solution
about AI I'd be I'd be a billionaire
because everyone wants to know the
solution to AI but I think the
discipline of verification has been a
thing that's been there for a hundred
years you have to check things out you
have to
verify look
man
the a year and a half ago I made a deep
fake of Nancy Pelosi and it was a
grotesque disgusting P picture and it
was hilarious a year later AI is so good
you can make a photorealistic picture of
Nancy Pelosi when it comes to video
verification is not the issue and I'll
tell you I'll give you the
example Donald Trump stands up at a
rally and says you had very fine people
on both sides and I am not talking about
the white supremacists because they
should be condemned totally we know that
video we know the media manipulated and
cut out of context what Trump said he
said I am not talking about the Nazis
and the white nationalists they should
be condemned totally the Deep fake issue
is not going to be a video of Donald
Trump saying something racist the Deep
fake video I'm scared of is Donald Trump
saying almost 90 99% Verbatim what he
did say but what they'll do is they'll
change it so whereas Trump actually said
and they should be condemned totally the
Deep fake version will go some of them
should be condemned totally and then no
one will know which one is the original
video because they're near identical the
left will say some of them should be
condemned oh man he's saying some of the
Nazis are good and then you'll argue no
no no he didn't actually say some of
them a deep fake no you're lying you
made the Deep fake Trump was defending
them right Biden already launched his
campaign off that lie and so that's one
example of the fear of a single word
being changed I see and it will be
weaponized and there's no verification
of it also like a presidential address
could be deep fix do you guys remember
when Jim M Costa tried ripping the mic
out of the hand of that White House Aid
MH and the country was split half of
people were like she tried ripping the
mic from Jim a Costa's hand and then the
other half was like aosta tried ripping
the mic from her hand and no one knew
for sure I think it's fair to say and
there were all these deep analysis
videos drawing lines and like figuring
out it's fairly obvious that Jim aosta
was was pulling the mic to try he was
trying to hold it and she was she was
she grabbed it and then he jerked to try
and pull it back from her because he was
trying to yell at Trump but either way
you have a video and no one agrees what
happened yeah but they had the kind of
quote George Carlin when he talked about
the World Plus plastic there'll be a new
paradigm where that will be what you
just described will be happening to
everyone and if that is true that DOTA
Trump then both sides will do it you
mentioned something about Pelosi so
there'll just be a new parad Paradigm
where where people will distrust things
a little more perhaps and and journalism
is all about trust and and who do you
trust but but I still I still stand by
my statement the discipline of
verification is something that existed
before video I mean people in newspapers
report according to people familiar with
the matter and they're reporting
anonymously sourced statements that we
don't have video of right so don't those
journalism rules apply to this new era
when everything is questionable people
will simply choose what confirms their
bias okay so with these with deep fakes
getting as good as they are yeah you're
going to you're going to say hold on was
Trump even really at that rally and then
you'll pull up the video and you'll be
like okay Trump really was there did he
actually say this there's two versions
of the same event you imagine a riot and
then they deep fake somebody into the
riot and then that person gets arrested
for being at the riot January like that
yeah stuff like that let let let me ask
you has this is the reality of politics
and a low trust you're talking about a
post truth Society we are there if if a
police officer says you broke the law
you did good luck good luck I was you
you go to court and you get a speeding
ticket and you say your honor I wasn't
speeding the cop says your honor he was
speeding guess what you lose that's it I
mentioned to you at uh in Miami at the
event that we did the IRL event that I
thought o'keef Media Group a cool thing
to do would be to build some technology
that can identify deep fakes because
you've got the trust and that would be
cool coming from you and your
organization or an organization that you
work with I think Trust TR is is is
critical journalis journalistic trust
they trust me why because of what I've
been through and there are other people
they trust too but I think that's that's
critical I think I don't know enough
about technology to build that but it's
a good idea but I also think here's one
thing they can't fake the person on the
inside going public the courageous thing
that can't be a fake if someone says I
work for the IRS the lowest learner or I
work for the FBI or I work for this
institution and you know what I'm
jumping on a grenade for my country that
that's a real thing isn't it and then
there's a reaction from the institution
there's always well could counter oper
counter Intel Ops and things like that
there is there is I mean there is I mean
you're talking about a totally fake
world we totally post I'm a little bit
more of an optimist I believe there is
one truth can be verified through
multiple sources if one guy sends you a
video of another he basically acts as if
he's someone else let how many how many
how many people think you are a farri
they've been saying that for 20 years
but I've stopped using those words
recent
they us say a doctor tapes that Tim they
used 10 years ago remember that he's the
tape doctor he he doctors the tape I'm
like can you just name one by the way I
have no money I'm using Final Cut seven
I wish I knew how to they said with the
acorn story that I put CGI to make the
people's lips move I'm like I don't even
know how to put the font other than Cur
you know Curry or new but the last 24
hours of my life here's what I did I had
people message me from jet limo another
jet limo five sources and I was Cor
ating the information I had by talking
to multiple sources inside the company
to verify that guy was the real person's
name this is what journalists do they
they verify information by getting
multiple accounts of the version of
events to ensure that the thing that
they're looking at is real I think
that's what ethical journalists do
that's no no one does that anymore
that's what I mean there's nobody has
the time and it's laziness it's
incompetence it's it's a lack of usually
it's economics but my point is that
video of me talking to the bus driver if
if that wasn't my video which it was but
he said I work for jet limousine I do
face check.id I find his picture online
there's his LinkedIn I talk to his
colleague I talked to his boss then I
publish the video so I verified that the
video that I've taken is real and that
does you're right that doesn't happen
anymore and on social media I feel like
and maybe I'm biased but like
conservative moderate journalist would
maybe take all those steps but someone
who is trying to smear someone says I
don't care if it's not real in fact I
would prefer if you do not follow up
with me at all do not see that I have
not or they paint or they paint the New
York Times reporters paint this
elaborate using words like document show
how far the conservative group would go
to not run a foul of the law another way
of saying that is we check with our
lawyers to make sure what we do is legal
but they make it word it in such a way
or like this person who has been accused
of doctoring T based on some random you
know blog post from the internet that is
also not verified that has no backup
then site that it's just repeating the
lie and making it bigger I mean it's the
idea of like basically being a Google
felon right false information reported
about you that becomes part of the
circularly sourced information yes
Wikipedia if you got a video and they're
like this guy said This Racist stuff at
the company this this executive and then
it it it turns out to be a deep F yeah
yeah you see what you're saying how do
you verify that I mean one of the ways
you verify it for example is getting it
from two different sources from two
different angles and you know there are
different way I mean there's no hard and
fast there's no no hard and fast rule on
how to verify the thing but I tell my
reporters if you put a gun to your
mother's head are you 100% sure that
that that that's true before you report
it and that's the standard and Tim I
mean it's a good point it's worth
discussing I I just uh I I think I I I
there's got to be a way in this
posttruth world to verify that what
you're looking at is real there are
people who care about the truth and want
to know and will verify and I think
those are the people who are on our side
yeah they'll be there are Mindless
zealots who don't care I mean did you
see Hassan P's response to Ashley St
Clair no I I didn't he made this
ridiculous low IQ tweet where he was
like oh my God foreigners are flying on
planes how could this possibly happen oh
my God send help and all of his fans are
laughing and clapping for him because
it's it like when you got mindless
drones who don't know or don't care
there there there are two kinds of
people in this world I mean the truth is
there's like a ton of different kinds of
people but right now you've got the
people who are more independently minded
and they're they're wondering what am I
doing and and is it right and then you
have the other group that says I just
want to have the Pitchfork and be in the
mob that's it yeah I think 2024 it's the
year to focus on the people that care
about the truth and the other people are
just going to be friction thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 pm and become a
member over at timcast.net